i don't want to talk about ghosts yeah i
got rinsed from the comments last time
did you actually wait what did you say
oh when i talked about ghosts people
were very angry that i spoke about i was
like
you don't believe him yeah
but then it was one of those that was
another one of those times i was like
damn i wish i could like go write a
[ __ ] script on why i don't believe in
ghosts and why they're stupid new videos
come back
why i don't believe in ghosts yeah there
was a there's a guy who made like uh
he made
a follow-up video about us talking about
ghosts basically oh really yes basically
saying my point but eloquent and
actually and actually explaining
what is this video called is bob what's
his name dark viper a you i think he
watches trash taste a lot
just he's a speedrunner right and while
he was speedrunning games he was just
giving this amazingly amazingly eloquent
explanation as to why people believe in
ghosts and why yeah
generally like a coping thing and
whatnot yeah you know it's stuff that i
normally agree with but it's one of
those things that you can never change
if someone believes in ghosts you're
never going to change their mind yeah
yeah but but it's like but for me to be
like i don't believe in it sometimes
people get offended by that they're like
never experienced it even if i did i
wouldn't care but the thing is i've
never experienced it but i still believe
in it yeah yeah because it's i don't
know it's it's cool
i understand that it's nice to believe
in but it's just one of those things
that i'm just like maybe i'm just too
boring i don't know to me it just
doesn't make sense i mean to me i
believe it yeah
but that's i didn't believe it until i
experienced something and then i did
believe it so yeah but again i always
think there's a logical explanation for
everything oh no of course of course
yeah i think there's there's always a
an explanation that might be boring
might not be immediately obvious uh they
can explain that well i mean yeah like
every every mystery ever in history you
know that's ever been solved has turned
out to be not magic right it's like yeah
there's always there's always something
behind it yeah yeah there's there's
always there's always something like we
just don't have the capability to
understand certain things and yeah i
guess the people use that argument for
you that's that could mean that we don't
ghosts could be real we don't understand
that we're like yeah but everything else
in our world thus far has has proven to
be the case stuff like that doesn't tend
to be yeah i believe in like the
supernatural or like the paranormal but
i don't believe in 99 percent of the
media that comes out this is like excuse
me i guess
that i really despise and this is one
thing that i absolutely hate about and
which really leads me to feel strongly
against it is the whole industry that's
propped up around
it's so predatory at times yeah that it
makes me just want to like just get rid
of it all just yeah no no one don't
believe in ghosts because if one person
believes in ghosts then there has to be
someone who then gets into believing
into ghosts and then falls down this
whole rabbit hole uh their husband dies
someone comes to them tells me i'll let
you speak to your husband for fifty
dollars now that [ __ ] is like that well
that that is that is that is predatory
yeah that is predatory and that's like
that's kind of different that's just
people taking advantage of people who
are like very vulnerable and very just
looking for answers and
but i believe there are people out there
who i wouldn't class as vulnerable but
maybe gullible more so oh yeah there's
nothing bad happen to them they're maybe
more likely to believe this kind of
stuff and i suppose you can't argue that
they're not getting what they want
they're they're paying for some [ __ ]
yeah but that's kind of what in my eyes
it's [ __ ] but oh
well maybe they'll ask for so i have
friends very good friends who go to
fortune tellers and stuff and i just
flat out just do not believe fortune
challenge oh no i don't believe that i
don't believe in that shitty deal i just
you know i think there is um
there are a lot of questions that would
be a raise oh so you know how to read
fortunes then uh why don't why are you
not very fortunate why are you not using
this to your ability if you yeah why do
you not own about ten portions of a
fortune's able to be changed is this
something you know and if if not why why
just bespoke uh bestowed you with this
knowledge of old people and why are you
not using it to your own advantage yeah
i just find that there are so many
questionable actions
and ultimately it all comes down to the
fact that you're charging money yeah
you're getting paid well um
you're free to believe in whatever the
[ __ ] you want as long as you're not like
extorting people yeah i mean
when you when you add when you add money
into the mix of course it's going to get
[ __ ] messy especially especially if
you try to like monetize this and i
think i think yeah if you want to give
away a fortune for free go ahead no yeah
yeah
but like i you know to like claim that
you have some kind of special power or
something but there's no way to prove
that and yes there right now whether you
believe in ghosts or not there is no
tangible proof
for or against for me like i believe i
believe in the supernatural i believe in
supernatural things because to me i
believe that
at the moment there is so much about the
universe and the world that even science
consciousness yeah like i believe that i
believe i'm i'm near certain alien
species out there exist that we have not
been able to you know come across
because the universe is too big but like
the whole concept of modern ghosts and
the way that we understand them i think
is completely incorrect but what is the
cons what is the concept of modern
ghosts like the idea that someone would
die and they're just going to hang
around a place haunting it like what
like are you serious no no that's not
going to i believe in it no no god no
but it's also
but it's also because like a lot of like
shintoist belief revolving right on that
i understand that and i kind of want to
grow up with it that's why i you know
it's one of the it's very tough for me
to argue uh again like i'm not prepared
i don't think we're gonna talk about it
yeah yeah no i'm not eloquent enough go
and watch this video this time
that's great i don't know like i i just
generally am of a scientific mindset uh
that's just absolutely appreciated i'm
most of the time i am generally
favorable towards the science stuff
like i don't believe in like [ __ ]
like people who can read like star signs
and meridian lines yeah i'm sure if you
if you presented some kind of paranormal
activity that we had and we really sat
down and we really went through it and
we really started poking holes in it we
could probably you know debunk most
things oh yeah i'm sure any of the stuff
that is generally when you say it's
unsolvable or nothing to explain there's
generally a massive lack of information
or not enough stuff to do but that's
what i mean right it's like it's it's a
lot like like ufo footage where it's
like yeah i believe in ufos but i don't
believe in 99 of the photos or videos
yeah exactly like a lot of the the
scandalous stuff yeah yeah same with
ghosts but ufos for sure because we know
that they exist there are tons of
unidentified objects we don't [ __ ]
know anything about but there are also a
lot of like you know haunted videos and
like paranormal activity like videos and
photos that it's just like no matter how
you look at it it's unexplained it's
become such a
and yeah i i think i feel like you just
hate the culture around it right i do i
really do
rather than yeah yeah i hate the culture
like i never talk about this because i'm
just like yeah i believe in ghosts and i
hardly mention it because it's just like
i believe in it because i've seen it i
don't really like like to talk about it
because it's just it's my experience
right it's just it's just you can't
force someone to believe in it i i don't
want other people to believe what like
experience what i experienced that's
just my experience i think it's done
personally but i'll never be like you're
a stupid person for believing in it yeah
and i'm not going to be like how dare
you don't believe yeah because you guys
you guys you guys have some form of some
belief in it i would never be like i
think you guys are stupid because you
believe in it i personally to me it
feels dumb yeah the idea of it yeah but
i don't care if anyone else no and i and
i i'm completely fine with people who
don't believe in it because you know it
can't be helped right it's like you
haven't experienced it of course you're
not gonna believe in it yeah because
like to me it's like the opposite sense
where yes i i completely agree the
culture is very messy it's very very
sensationalized which i hate psychics
there's been so many like people who
have debunked people who have monetized
this that how can you not
know that a lot of people are just
predatory but at the same time i do
believe there is a lot of things that
have not been able to explain
with current science and i think it's
even i think i think it's naive to not
think that there is something not
something more out there that hasn't
been explained yet because there's so
many there's so much about you know
there's so much we don't understand we
we take for granted because science says
science has evolved and progressed so
much that we forget how much we still do
not [ __ ] understand yeah
about just the united states everything
about everything i guess right like
generally my my thought process along
that is if we don't understand the
situation and we don't have the tools to
explain it i i don't think that a
paranormal explanation is the correct
one because you know we didn't know we
didn't know what caused like cholera for
a long time yeah you know i'm sure at
some point they thought it was it was
the devil right
it's one of those things where it's like
generally when we've come to at least my
belief is that when we we just don't
have the tools or the knowledge of
subsequent fields or physics or math to
understand certain things but also most
of the time it's so [ __ ] minuscule
what happened it doesn't [ __ ] matter
like if your door closed one night and
it was real spooky it's like why would
anyone delve deep into trying to
disprove you your door uncomfortably
closed it's called a draft
although watch the paranormal activity
once yeah i can see the string right
there are so many things that are so
not worth explaining oh yeah generally
most of the [ __ ] that is spooky is so
not worth wasting time on trying to
figure out because there's so little
information that we have yeah that's not
worth explaining anyway well that's the
problem
one more thing
i also do want to acknowledge that there
is you know the whole psychic stuff and
all that i do understand that there is a
market that is pure entertainment yeah
right i could go to a fortune teller
they could tell me a bunch of nonsense i
don't believe a word they said but it
was fun to hear the funny words that
they tell me
i understand that's an angle and i'm
fine with that i like your funny words
magical things magic man thank you for
telling me that i'm going to be wealthy
i appreciate that but i'm i'm also like
going to hear when i've i've i've gone
to a fortune teller before because i
like i like to experience what kind of
generic way they're going to tell me
about my future yeah i love to
understand the way that they're trying
to do it yeah but that's not of a place
of uh
me genuinely believing it but i do think
that it is kind of yeah
there are a lot of people out there who
really believe in this stuff yeah yeah i
i i almost my mom's one of those people
and i'm like i'm like some sometimes my
mom like takes me to a fortune teller
and i'm like mom again my mom again you
get the same [ __ ] spiel every time
proven that you know they say generic
things it can apply to anyone it's cold
reading cold reading is a technique
psychics not so much in the supernatural
sense but more on the psychological
sense of being like darren brown is more
along i'm not he always says he's not
psychic but like just using the faults
of the human yeah
psychology
and that's like more interesting
that would never claim to be psychic or
yeah nothing like that they understand
that it's a lot more than that because
claiming that psychic really undervalues
what you're doing yeah yeah really
magic brain thing yeah
do i but do i believe in like psychics
and people who can cold read and stuff
like that no do i believe there are
people out there who can maybe sense
some supernatural things yes i do i
don't really yeah i don't care enough i
mean i mean i think it's because again
like god and i have personal experience
of either ourselves or someone we know
this comes from just my understanding
the the brain is just so flawed in many
ways and that of course yeah you know
there's been like
uh i know someone gave an argument this
i saw a comment that was arguing about
this and it was just like if you can't
prove it what's the what's that really
horrible argument method where it's like
if you can't prove it's
not real
then it then it is real yeah and it's
like no no no no you need you the burden
is proving that it's real not that it
isn't well that's that's that's this is
what i i find the most annoying about
arguing the subject is that for some
reason it's on the burden to me to prove
that you don't have magical sixth sense
now prove to me
concretely that you do yeah that's the
same people who say like oh yes proof is
a synonym for true it's like no it's
really not well that's that's the thing
that's
there's no way to prove it right now and
that's why it's we call believing it
but there's so many things right have
you watched naruto
there's that
[ __ ] it's like
shut the [ __ ] up i'm about to [ __ ]
leave right now okay so like believe it
there's so many like you know i'm trying
to argue a point here joey don't argue a
[ __ ] point here there's just so many
goddamn clips of people you know where
they they go to people who are like yeah
i can talk to the dead or i can feel the
dead and then they show them pictures of
people who aren't dead they're like
they're like hey they're not dead
they're like oh well you know it's like
this happens so many goddamn times so
it's like at what point are we just
gonna be like come on this is just
[ __ ] literally everyone who claims
they can do this somewhere or another
when they put the test they fail like
rarely no one ever passes these tests
why but like most of the time like most
most of the people i've met who have
stories around this it's got nothing to
do with this the sensationalized [ __ ]
you see on tv that's true
but that's that's what also makes it
very difficult to have a discussion yeah
people have their beliefs they're so
strong in their beliefs that they don't
consider that they could have maybe
experienced something that wasn't there
yeah more often than not they never
like arguing about someone with their
religion right which is right
you never like it's it's just it's just
a lose-lose argument because either you
believe in religion or you don't and
it's neither according to the other side
neither is right or wrong yeah terrible
admitting our own faults as human beings
right there's so many like you know you
go to criminal cases there's so many
like uh trials and stuff where
eyewitness testimony has been given and
they swear 100 they have nothing to lose
by lying about this that they saw
something happened that turned out it
didn't happen and that their memory
because memory is so unreliable and
feelings are so unreliable and what you
see is never exactly what you remember
it to be these things we are so terribly
inconsistent as humans that i find it
hard to believe that one person who
experienced sang so
so wildly kind of outer worldly and that
we don't is it out of worldly though i
mean they're they're a big
sometimes i've heard stuff where i'm
like no and there's something so i'm
like you know that just sounds like you
had an experience that i wouldn't
describe as
um like that's like a ghost thing it's
like you just had an experience yeah
that isn't like a ghost or haunted i
said you felt something and i thought
that was a you thing i don't think that
was the world that you know what i mean
i feel like that's you that's like
that's the youth
i was in the same room with you at the
exact same time i would not have
experienced the same thing as you right
because it is entirely
a thing that is happening to you it's
it's it's a mental thing that's going on
i don't think it's a thing that's in
this like physical world or this
material world or whatever i think it's
something that if you put two people in
the same room and one of them's having
that kind of experience and they're
feeling things yeah like when you when
you went on that tour or whatever you
know there's like if you go on a tour
and you you know haunted house and why
one person feel things in one of my
doesn't i don't think it's a ghost
choosing oh spooky on the god you know
yeah i think it's you are setting your
your mind is capable you believe that
that could happen you are a person who
is susceptible to feeling that you could
be haunted so you go into a place
expecting maybe i could be haunted i'm
open to this idea something happens you
feel something and then you your mind
is like haunted or well i i i i could
argue the i could argue the complete
opposite right because i would never
yeah yeah i totally agree no because
like you you arguing the mentality that
they're susceptible to believing in this
thing but right on the opposite side of
on the opposite side of the fence you
are someone who's so adverse to this
idea that you would you're just shutting
it out that you would shut out whatever
experience if there was an experience if
there was right so like you never like
you never know you might have perhaps
experienced a similar paranormal theme
where in your head it's just like oh
that just happened yeah that was a bit
weird all right anyway brush it off
possibly i i think that it's
it's really tough because like you said
if it did happen i i would probably just
i would probably think of a logical
conclusion as to why that happened
exactly and more often than not i feel
like i can adequately explain what
happened where other people around me
whether there was a noise or something
that happened i can normally be like
that's what i find this whole like i
guess culture to be interesting about
right is that like we don't know like
both sides don't know and it's the
conversation of the believer versus the
non-believer who is right who the [ __ ]
knows but it's fun to talk about yeah i
think unfortunately there's people who
argue my side more often than not argue
the point that people who believe this
[ __ ] are dumb yeah and so it kind of
makes this really horrible
of course like that that like whole
sensationalized side of things like that
that's just that's just an image problem
right
it is it is so much of an image problem
because so much of the the media around
the supernatural is like sensationalized
especially
especially like [ __ ] with like halloween
you like
like [ __ ] tv is unfucking watchable
no i agree in halloween because
everything is like ghost specials
that's all the [ __ ] that's why like
even though i wasn't i wasn't saying
like you're [ __ ] stupid if you
believe this [ __ ]
the last time we spoke about this i got
like the comments people like were
saying to me they were some of them were
like really [ __ ] rude about it they
were like connor's just he just thinks
everyone's stupid if they don't believe
i'm like i didn't say that it's like i
personally i think that stuff to me yeah
is is dumb yeah but i would never be
like you're a dumb person i believe well
i i think the important thing is that
you like people recognize it is a belief
and people have experienced it sometimes
people can believe different things but
you never want to make them feel like
they've been discredited for feeling the
way they do i think that's why we have
such a tough political climate
because for a long time all these really
uh
extreme beliefs were like yeah you're
stupid they're the most i think that's
the problem as well is that there's
really a difference between people who
have a belief of like this could be true
and then the people who swear that is
true yeah and like like i'm one of those
people together yeah and they get mixed
together and it's like and that's where
like the bad image comes like i'm
definitely one of those people who is
the former where it's like i believe
this could be a possibility and i find
it more fun personally to think of it in
that sense but i'm not gonna come out
and say like ghosts are real 100 percent
no cap no no i mean all right like i'm
not going to say that like we just
discussed you can't prove ghosts are not
real but you can't prove ghosts or
[ __ ] reasons yeah exactly but like i
have more enjoyment i hate the argument
if you can't prove it i personally have
the enjoyment of thinking you know what
there is a possibility we just don't
know and that's what i find exciting
about believing in this thing yeah i
feel great for me for me it's like it's
it's less of just it's less of just like
this is a fun thing for me to believe
and it's more of just like you know
everyone's had different experience i've
had like my own experience as well and i
couldn't i guess like i couldn't
logically explain it and so what
happened was well
at this moment with my experiences and
what i've seen it's more likely for me
that it exists then it doesn't exist and
am i open to the fact that maybe what i
experienced wasn't real you know i'm
open either way but right now based on
my experience i'm just like yeah i
believe it and that's i think i believe
yeah
it's all about whether you're
no cat facts no printer it's all about i
guess like whether you're just like
naturally susceptible to i guess like
believing in things like spirituality
yeah i think that kind of
yeah it definitely comes i mean
everyone around me was quite religious
christian or catholic etc etc um i just
i think
my problem probably uh where i started
to grow a disdain towards that stuff is
i just didn't enjoy it when i was
younger like i hated church i hated all
that stuff right
and then you know when you get older and
you discover the internet you're like oh
wow i can do my own research and then
you start like googling stuff and yeah
and then
i don't know i think i was very and then
the four chance scientists come out
shadows
red build um